[Musique]
la mission que nous avons créée on
s'interroge sur les faiblesses du
commerce extérieur et l'un se
caractérise par une balance commerciale
excédentaire et aussi dans nos auditions
on s'est rendu compte que c'était
essentiellement les grandes entreprises
qui exportait alors que dans là c'est le
contraire presque 60% des exportations
relève d'entreprises de moins de 20
salariés c'est dû aussi en partie à la
spécialisation qu'il y a dans notre
département notamment avec de grands
pôles le pôle de la plasturgie le pôle
de compétitivité qui lui est lié le folk
polymérise
on a la chance d'avoir plusieurs sites
industriels
basés en france dans la région
rhône-alpes assez en france imiter les
uns des autres qui offre une garantie
une sécurité pour nos clients en termes
de fabrication en europe tu as turgis
est forte on ne peut pas dire qu'on doit
plus fort physiquement mais on est plus
forts des américains plus fort des
asiatiques - lorient n'y a rien du tout
et il est épatant choses un peu en
automobile mais
[Musique]
et qu'est ce qu'on y gagne d'abord nous
y gagnons une augmentation de volume une
consolidation de nos volumes donc de la
création et du développement de la
pérennisation et du développement de
l'emploi et puis après cette limiter les
risques parce que quand ça va un peu
moins bien en france allait un peu mieux
en allemagne quand ça va un peu mieux en
allemagne ça peut aller un peu de vie
aux états-unis au japon bref ne pas
mettre tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier c'est quand même l'article 1 de
la stratégie à l'export
les entrepreneurs ils sont tous sains à
développer leur affaire mais ils
trouvent pas ils trouvent pas de
personnel quel que soit le niveau c'est
une vraie quelle que soit la nature du
travail quel que soit le type
d'entreprise c'est quelque chose qu'on
rencontre partout depuis les artisans
fiscaux grands groupes et quelle que
soit la nature de l'activité
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne
également presque la totalité des
entreprises c'est le coût de l'énergie
le renchérissement absolument
invraisemblable puisqu'on on a une
multiplication par 2 3 5 du coût de
l'énergie est évidemment quand les
entreprises sont grosses utilisatrices
s'apaisent très fort sur les coûts